.
>>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
UNDER FIRE FROM THE FAR RIGHT
FOR FINALLY TELLING THE TRUTH.
THAT'S FOLLOWING COMMENTS HE
MADE DEFENDING THE FGTIVENESS OF
VACCINES.
HERE'S DECHDABLE TRUMP ALLY
AFTER TRUMP INSISTED TO HER THAT
VACCINES WORK.
>> YOU OFTEN TIMES FORGET HOW
OLD TRUMP IS.
HE COMES FROM A GENERATION.
I HAVE SEEN OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
THE SAME PERSPECTIVE.
THEY CAME FROM A TIME BEFORE TV,
BEFORE INTERNET, BEFORE BEING
ABLE TO CONDUCT THEIR
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH AND
EVERYTHING THIS THEY READ IN A
NEWSPAPER THAT WAS PITCHED TO
THEM.
THEY IT BELIEVED THAT WAS A
RATTLE.
I BELIEVE ALSO THAT HE ONLY
READS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA NEWS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE TRUMP OF READS
OR PARTAKES IF ANY OTHER NEWS
SOURCES.
I DON'T BELIEVE TRUMP IS ON THE
INTERNET.
>> CLEAN UP ON AISLE TRUMP.
JOINING ME NOW IS ANALYST AND
COLUMNIST KRISTIN POWERS AND CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AIRL
AEROLEWIS.
WHAT DOES THIS BACKLASH SAY
ABOUT HIS PACE BASE OF SUPPORT
AND THE WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS
AND SOME OF THE SHIFT IN FAULT
LINES?
>> WHAT IT SAYS ABOUT HIS BASE
IS THAT SOME OF THEM ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE'S MORE A
AT STAKE HERE THAN SIMPLY
SUPPORTING THE PRESIDENT AND
GOING DOWN WHATEVER PATH OF BS
THAT HE WANTS TO HAND OUT TO
THEM.
THAT NOT WORK AS POLITICS, BUT
THE REALITY IS THERE'S A LOT A
AT STAKE WHEN YOU'RE TUG ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES, TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE SEEN WHAT
HAPPENED AT THEIR LOCAL HOSPITAL
AND FILLING UP OF THE ICUs.
SO THEY ARE NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO RUN DOWN THIS PATH WITH
HIM, SO HE FINDS IT NOW
DIFFICULT TO INJECT A NOTE OF
TRUTH INTO THE TORRENT OF LIES
THAT IT LED TO HIM BEING VOTED
OUT OF OFFICE.
HE'S IN A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE
OF HIS OWN MAKING.
>> THIS WAS JUST REALLY AN
UNBELIEVABLE EXCHANGE TO WATCH
CANDACE OWENS AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THIS AND
HIM PUSHING BACK SAYING JUST THE
TRUTH ABOUT VACCINES AND
BOOSTERS AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
BUT SHE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE NOW
TRYING TO TALK IN THE AFTERMATH.
ALEX JONES IS ALSO CRITICIZING
TRUMP OVER WHAT HE SAID.
>> IT'S AN EMERGENCY CHRISTMAS
DAY WARNING TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU ARE EITHER COMPLETELY
IGNORANT ABOUT THE SO-CALLED
VACCINE GENE THERAPY THAT YOU
HELPED RAM THROUGH WITH
OPERATION WARP SPEED OR ONE OF
THE MOST EVIL MEN WHO HAS EVER
LIVED.
TO PUSH THIS TOXIC POISON ON THE
PUBLIC AND TO ATTACK YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THEY SIMPLY
TRIED TO SAVE THEIR LIVES AND
TH
THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
>> NOW WE SHOULD REPEAT TRUMP
WAS JUST QUITE LITERALLY TELLING
THE TRUTH ABOUT VACCINES WHEN HE
WAS PUSHING BACK ON CANDACE
OWENS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED TO SEE WHAT
SHE'S SAYING IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THIS AND WHAT ALEX JONES IS
SAYING A ABOUT THIS?
>> NOT REALLY BECAUSE YOU REALLY
CAN'T PUT THE GENIE BACK IN THE
BOTTLE.
WHAT TRUMP UNLEASHED CAN'T BE
UNDONE.
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE PARODYING THIS
LINE, TELLING ALL THEIR
FOLLOWERS THIS IS THE CASE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO JUST TURN
AROUND ON A DIME AND SAY, OOPS,
WE WERE WRONG BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP SAYS THIS, BECAUSE HOW
STUPID WOULD THEY LOOK.
AND I GUESS WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
CANDACE OWENS, SHE LIVES IN A
WORLD WHERE YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
GET MEDICAL INFORMATION ON
OBSCURE WEBSITES ON THE
INTERNET.
THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT WORLD
VIEW THAT EVEN DONALD TRUMP
DOESN'T ASCRIBE TO.
HE'S BASICALLY JUST SAYING WHAT
IS TRUE, WHAT THE DOCTORS ARE
SAYING, AND SHE'S SAYING HE
DOESN'T REALLY KNOW THAT BUZZ
HE'S OLD AND DOESN'T SPEND HIS
TIME BASICALLY GOING DOWN RABBIT
HOLES ON THE INTERNET TO GET
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
IT'S JUST IS SUCH AN ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE.
I DON'T THINK IT CAN BE UNDONE.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS THINGS ABOUT THE TRUMP
ERA IS THAT EVEN IF HE WANTED TO
TRY TO PULL IT BACK, I DON'T
THINK HE CAN.
>> I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT'S ALSO SHOW ING THAT ANOTHER
OLD ANCIENT WISDOM IS THEY TURN
ON THEIR CREATOR.
CONGRESSWOMAN DINGELL SHARED A
VOICE MAIL THAT WAS LEFT FOR HER
RECENTLY.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> YOU [ BLEEP ].
YOU'RE AS OLD AND UGLY AS BIDEN.
YOU OUGHT TO GET THE [ BLEEP ]
OFF THE PLANET.
YOU [ BLEEP ].
THEY OUGHT TO TRY YOU FOR
TREASON.
EVERY ONE OF YOUR SCUM BAG
FRIENDS.
I HOPE YOUR FAMILY DIES IN FRONT
OF YOU.
I HOPE YOUR CHILDREN THEY IT DIE
IN YOUR FACE.
>> THAT KIND OF HATE WE'RE
PLAYING BECAUSE SHE SAYS SHE
RECEIVES THESE VOICE MAIL
REGULARLY.
IS THIS PAR FOR THE COURSE
THESE DAYS?
DOES AIR ING THESE KINDS OF VOIE
MAILS MAYBE HELP BREAK THE
FEVER?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT LAST
PART.
THIS IS THE CASE OF A
RADICALIZATION OF AMERICAN
POLITICS.
THE POISONING OF AMERICAN
THIS IS THE SAME STATEMENTS
WHERE THERE WAS A PLOT THAT WAS
BROKEN UP AND ONE MAN PLEADED
GUILTY TO KIDNAP GOVERNOR
WHITMER.
THERE WAS A BACKUP PLAN TO HOLD
A WEEK-LONG TRIAL AND EXECUTE
LEGISLATORS OF THE MICHIGAN
LEGISLATURE.
THERE IS A STREAK OF RADICALISM
OUT THERE THAT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
YOU JUST SHOWED US A SAMPLE OF
IT.
PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
FBI HAS BEEN WARNING ABOUT THIS
FOR TWO DECADES NOW.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
THIS ISN'T MADE UP.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CONFRONT AS A
NATION AND WHEN LAWMAKERS ARE
BEING THREATENED IN THE WAY YOU
JUST DISPLAYED, WE SHOULD ALL BE
ALARMED.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I WAS LIKE THIS.
I DON'T GET THE VOICE MAILS, BUT
I GET THE E-MAILS.
THE THING IS THAT ANYBODY WHO IS
IN THE PUBLIC EYE IN THE TRUMP
ERA CAN TELL YOU, AND ETC.
HERBALLY HAVING BEEN ON TV
PRETRUMP ERA THAT SOMETHING
HAPPENED AFTER HE CAME INTO
OFFICE.
THESE KINDS OF E-MAILS AND VOICE
MESSAGES HAVE BECOME PRETTY
COMMON PLACE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
I THINK PARTICULARLY FOR WOMEN
WHO ARE ON TV AND ANY TIME --
DEBBI DINGELL IS NOT A
PARTICULARLY CONTROVERSIAL
PERSON.
SO SHE'S A MODERATE DEMOCRAT
FROM A MIDWEST ERIN STATE.
THIS IS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
AND SOMETHING IS QUALITATIVELY
DIFFERENT.
ANYBODY CAN TELL YOU THAT.
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT I
RECEIVE NOW ON A REGULAR ALMOST
DAILY BASIS MAYBE HAPPENED ONCE
A YEAR BEFORE.
SO AGAIN, WHAT I WAS SAYING
EARLIER, TRUMP HAS UNLEASHED
SOMETHING IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
JUST CANT BE PUT BACK IN THE
BOTTLE.
AS ERROLL WAS SAYING, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED, THIS KIND OF HATRED
AS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T ACT ON THE
THINGS